hello let's talk religion so there's
been a lot of discussion lately about
the shape of the earth and I think none
of us have escaped the rise of the
so-called flat earthers that is people
who believe that well of the earth is
flat and so many people this is
absolutely ridiculous I mean how can
they be people real people in 2018 that
believe that the earth is flat the
discussions we see on social media and
in comments sections can get very heated
and a lot of times there is more
name-calling and swearing than actual
debate but after all are we supposed to
support the idea of free speech I mean
these people have all the right in the
world to believe that the earth is flat
I mean it isn't but that's not the point
the real value lies in our ability to
debate and discuss these things isn't to
present arguments and ideas to support
our claims I mean there's a million
videos on the internet about people
arguing for a spherical earth so that's
not really what I'm interested in doing
I mean I could argue that the shadow of
the earth that's projected on the moon
is obviously round but I'm not a
scientist so I don't feel like that's my
place to do so what does concern me and
touches on my area of study is our view
of the historical aspects of this
question and indeed its connection to
religion as well they're seen to be this
common idea that we believed that the
earth was flat up until only a few
hundred years ago I remember learning in
school that it was Columbus that
discovered the earth was round I mean
that's the people believed is that a
thing do people believe Columbus did
that in any case in debates about this
subject this argument often comes up the
round earth theory is a result of post
enlightenment science and thus in
opposition also to religious beliefs in
other words that religions believe the
earth is flat and science knows that
it's round only problem is this is wrong
and a grave Mis reading of history and
the history of this subject the idea of
a spherical earth didn't just pop up a
few hundred years ago I mean we've known
that the earth is round for over 2,000
years the ancient Greeks already figured
this out in the 3rd century BC in fact
Aristotle who we all know and love
looked up at the stars and realized that
the constellations of the stars changed
depending on where you were on the
ground and thus concluded that the earth
must be round a while later
Aristophanes actually attempted to
calculate this circum for
of the earth using different shadows in
different parts of the world and came up
with results that are impressively close
to the actual size even more impressive
is perhaps the experiments made in the
later Islamic world by abu rayhan al
biruni of 10th century persian polymath
they were also attempted to calculate
the circumference of the earth using an
ingenious method including geometry and
algebra first he found a mountain and
measured its height he then measured the
angle of the horizon from the top of the
mountain using a device known as an
astrolabe with this information the
height of the mountain and the angle of
the horizon once on top of the mountain
he used trigonometry to figure it out
that these two are related to the radius
of the earth and thus he could make a
prediction about its size the result he
came up with are amazingly with an
inaccuracy of less than 1% in other
words not only was he and his
contemporaries very much aware of the
earth was round in the 10th century he
actually figured out its size not only
is this an amazing achievement it also
shows that the idea of the Flat Earth as
a dominant scientific position
historically is very problematic another
very telling example of this is from the
Arabic philosophical tale hiya bin young
son buy a bin to fame who we covered in
a previous video in the very first
sections of the book which is from the
12th century by the way he writes this
it has been proven with scientific
certainty that the Sun is spherical as
is the earth and that the Sun is much
bigger than the earth again here we have
a devout Muslim and scientists writing
long before the Enlightenment or
Columbus stating with such confidence
that the spherical nature of the earth
is indisputable and a scientific fact I
often wonder why people are so inclined
to believe that the pre-enlightenment
world believed that the earth was flat
any reading of history general history
or the history of religions will tell
you that this is not the case when it
comes to religion first of all it's
impossible to say that my religion
believes this or that but we have shown
here that the concept of a spherical
earth has not been a foreign concept at
all for thinkers from different
religious traditions like Islam or
Christianity but as of
been accepted as scientific truth now of
course I'm not saying that the
scientific discoveries of the last few
hundred years hasn't made it much more
clear what the actual answer to this
question is or that indeed everyone in
the medieval world believed the earth
was round of course not during the time
of al biruni ribbon to fail a lot of
people did probably believe that the
earth was flat and probably a lot more
than today but I am saying is that the
history of the subject as it's taught in
schools and so on is often very
inaccurate and undermines the
achievements of the medieval and and
also ancient worlds why are we given
this view of history well many argue
that the Enlightenment wanted so badly
to be viewed as this turning point in
human history that it often exaggerated
the unenlightened nature of the periods
before it was in a lot of ways and move
away from religion and towards science
and thus religion was associated with
unenlightened beliefs and any positive
aspects of religion was often also
removed from it I mean we're still
seeing the results of this today as many
don't realize how long we've actually
known the shape of the earth so next
time you argue with a flat earther maybe
point out that they're not just opposing
Massa or some modern scientific
corporation but a 2,000 year old
tradition I'll see you next time
[Music]